hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction all right
when we left off we just got back to the
laboratory or we just got into the
laboratory through the horrifying dark
parts of the storage room oh this looks
nice I like this I don't like torture
devices they are no fun not fun for the
whole family
whoa again primary ingredient Wolfsbane
root potion hallucinates what feverishly
touch of influenza conclusion failure
yeah you're a big failure look through
your book what are you gonna do now come
at me moose man another failure note
berries from a dogwood tree yep failure
epic failure killing him instantly
ooh red postulating boils screaming
agony as they eventually burst killing
him instantly
also not fun for the whole family
laudanum poor soul yeah I know an
exploded guy bat bad bat
bad bad
okay I think he might be gone baby lots
of odd enough
lots of tinderboxes hello
No
hello okay we're good we're good well
good I wasn't scared I'm wasting oil
again oh man not a problem so great um
we got here more bets that are gonna
explode on me there we go
nope come here come here I could hear
them the screams of my former cellmates
fills me with the deepest dread one can
imagine does a mistress knowing if we're
here I'm talking kill him before he gets
to me pierce his foul harp all I have is
this bucket huh yeah hid the letter in a
rush okay oh no no no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
okay okay I got a bucket oh I got a
bucket I got a bucket don't look at me
dude look at me I got a bucket no I'm
[ __ ] you betrayed me oh he's so ugly
oh he's so ugly oh why is he here why is
he here why is he here can I get out can
I get out [ __ ] it I don't trust you
anymore bucket you're you're bad luck I
can't eat right there get out get out
get out
I gotta sneak past him I gotta sneak
past him I suppose that sounds about
right
Oh moose man okay
ohokay he's leaving oh I was about to
sneak past him and he was leaving Oh
Eddie I get out of here moves man
no one likes you moves man yeah that
Yunior you and your ugly face okay he's
gone
all right oh man that guy's terrifying
huh and ugly too and fat what a loser no
friend this doesn't look good
yeah this looks like a bundle of fun
Oh what is this broken pieces of glass a
note another note of failure final test
traveling to another realm time has come
becomes possible when the soul leaves
the body it seems a barrier prey the
work is not miss list misled me I'm
Dylan yes plan is to drink a potion
which will stop my heart I do not know
her blah blah blah this must be
Alexander and how we got yeah Alexander
and how he got into the world that
Daniel is from and this must be his
bones aw fu buddy okay that's weird
all right nothing else in here just some
backstory all right
oh come at me moose man I'm so ready for
you get outta here
okay barrels boxes tinderboxes God uh
those are torture devices they'd like
somebody's oh I got so many why don't I
use them I don't know I don't know I
don't know because I'm an idiot okay op
of course P nearby okay whenever
something says it's nearby that means
it's probably in the same room but in
this case doesn't look like that is true
maybe maybe tinderbox laudanum man they
are loading me up with laudanum I wonder
if they plan on hurting me like that
cave sequence where the spiders not rats
bit me ten bajillion times like give me
like look okay I ran in here screaming
my head off so time to come back how
many do I have a forty nine tinderboxes
my goodness what a waste of oil good
thing I managed to stock up a while ago
okay reanimating dead flesh failure was
to create artificial life - longer than
expected slight movement oh good
low guttural groan Oh hmm its face had
bed come contorted in a terrifying way
gotcha this is how he made moose man hey
good for you oh hey news man
shouldn't have done it bro alright it's
gotta be huh what what what Monica what
what what what what why oh here's a
bunch of laudanum bone to bone the key
key bone
test two Emmys permanent amnesia and
twisting flesh except there's a bra
without a knowledge and needs a potion
move towards him with a saw
I began cutting off his left arm the
intention of replacing it with a weapon
he screamed for blood-curdling despite
the constant use of laudanum oh this is
more mousse man cuz mousse man has the
big metal arm mental wiring in the flesh
the subject had expired
I get it you've died and then he
reanimated moose man okay still haven't
found a key maybe you need to keep me
the key me the key key key key okay yeah
I missed a lot of doors running
screaming gonna head off
there's another note give me a key
Amador you think I got plenty I've gotta
stop using it though cuz I'm an idiot
take that Alexander Damascus rose petals
oh let's see ya begin actually questions
secession
success Damascus rose petals okay the
oil they secrete oh that's what she said
yeah ah bones is so scary tinderboxes
all right what do we have laudanum more
man how many Lana I'm nine why do I have
nine he's don't know key artificial life
seems life is much more difficult to
produce and I originally thought
Oh No kidding yeah alright whatever
nokey dokey man there's the key pourcel
yeah I know it's sad he's dead get over
it
Daniel you're such a pansy alright I had
enough of your pans eNOS in the last
game also you're a murdering bastard I
forgot that you are a murdering but oh
oh it was in that room of course it was
of course of course I'm a big idiot ah
whatever
whatever doesn't matter it doesn't
matter okay moving on give me this
through the door moose man I bet is
gonna follow me as soon as I open this
door huh hey ah there we go
gimme close oh so nice oh hello ladies
how you doing
mmm so brightly lit welcoming thank you
so much the question mark question mark
Oh ooh wow this is gonna be the last
part Hey